the murder of a navy communications
officer led NCIS agents on a trail of
deception and lies ending at an unlikely
trio of suspects
the dramatic investigation is part of
tonight's season three premiere of the
CBS series NCIS the cases they can't
forget real NCIS agents recall some of
their most significant missions the host
rocky Carroll one of the stars of the
hit CBS drama NCIS
he shows us now what to expect in
tonight's episode roadmap to murder Cory
Voss was a young Navy sailor with a
promising naval career but unfortunately
that career was cut short by his murder
this case involved three suspects and
illicit love affair a hitman and the
woman at the center of the story loved
nothing more than money that was her
true love and life Cory Voss had
returned from a deployment and he was at
home with his wife Catherine Avast also
known as Kat and they had had a romantic
dinner cat tells Cory that she needs
some money for the children's lunches
the next day it's full so she asked him
to go to the ATM an individual dressed
on all black entered the passenger side
of his vehicle and pointed a weapon at
Cory and what we now know he went to an
adjacent parking lot Newport News police
arrived at the parking lot and find Cory
Voss deceased in his vehicle with
multiple gunshot wounds my sergeant and
I responded to talk with myth cat Voss
she became hysterical screaming this
appeared to be a robbery gone bad and
this just seemed like it was overkill
throughout the investigation leads led
us to multiple individuals involved with
the murder of Cory Voss one suspect
David Runyon they stopped his car and
found what investigators call the
smoking map and on that map was
handwritten Langley Federal Credit Union
a great detailed description of Cory
Voss's truck as well as Cory's name
written on there I thought how dumb
could this
bb2 still have in his possession
something of such significance that
unequivocally links him to Cory Voss
I've never come across a triangle of
three individuals with no connection
initially that ended up in a
cold-blooded murder of somebody who was
totally innocent and you can watch road
map to murder tonight at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS it'll be
followed by a second NCIS the cases they
can't forget episode that one's called
heartless people can't get enough for
true crime stories we are here to serve